a British TV channel is defending its
decision to play intimate tapes Princess
Diana recorded in a new documentary it
airs this weekend ahead of the 20th
anniversary of her death the tapes were
made during private sessions with her
speech coach and they've never been
shown in Britain in those tapes Princess
Diana speaks openly about her life and
her troubled marriage to Prince Charles
Charlie d'Agata is outside Kensington
Palace in London Charlie good morning
good morning it was behind these walls
at Princess Diana's Kensington Palace
where the conversations took place
critics say behind those walls is where
it should have stayed out of respect to
the controversy we've chosen not to take
any direct quotes from the documentary
the documentary is called Diana in her
own words whether Princess Diana ever
wanted to share those words to a wider
audience is another matter
this is like people stopping for a
motorway pileup to see if there are any
dead bodies it's just it's just horrible
royal biographer penny Junor says Diana
would never have revealed such intimate
facts about her personal life or married
life even her sex life knowing her son's
may one day hear it they are deeply
personal
they are extremely they would will be
extremely humiliating to the Prince of
Wales damaging to the royal family
hurtful to William and Harry and Donna's
sisters and brother they were filmed by
Diana's speech coach in 1992 to 93 right
around the time Diana separated from
Prince Charles even Diana's former
Butler Paul Burrell at one point in
possession of the tapes who has himself
being criticized for spilling Diana's
secrets called airing the conversations
CD it's almost like reading her diary
British broadcaster Channel four says
the tapes and therefore the programme
are historically significant to be able
to find a three and a half or four hours
of conversations where she's talking
about herself and effectively putting
her own version of the story he's an
amazing historical document and I think
if it
it allows us to create a new portrait of
dialer Dioner and one that's very
illuminating now the lawyer representing
Diana's voice coach won't say how much
his client got paid for the tape saying
it's completely irrelevant now in
defense he said since Diana's death a
whole industry of people have been
willing to give their take on what Diana
was feeling said surely the authority on
that is no better than Diana herself
Vlad Charlie d'Agata in London Charlie
thank you